Game of Thrones fans witnessed the death of
Khal Drogo long ago, when the powerful warlord
perished at the hands of his then-wife Daenerys
Targaryen.
It was tough to say goodbye to the Dothraki
warrior, who proved himself to be something
of a sensitive man when not engaged in acts
of violence on the battlefield.
Few can forget how they felt when they watched
Dany smother him with a pillow to put him
out of his misery after he was poisoned by
a vengeful magician.
These episodes premiered in 2011, which feels
like a lifetime ago.
But Khal Drogo experienced something of a
second death when actor Jason Momoa shaved
off his signature beard for the first time
since 2012.
Momoa, who appeared as Khal Drogo on Game
of Thrones for only 10 episodes and still
managed to win the hearts of millions, posted
a video of himself shearing off his famous
facial hair to his YouTube channel on April
17.
Out in the open wilderness, presumably on
location filming the Dune reboot, the actor
took an electric clipper to his beard.
With each chunk he shaved off, the actor bid
farewell to a character he played while rocking
it.
"Bye, Drogo.
Bye, Arthur Curry."
The actor quickly revealed that he wasn't
getting rid of his whiskers all willy-nilly.
Rather, Momoa stripped his strapping face
of all its hair and stubble for a good cause:
to increase awareness about the importance
of reducing plastic to help preserve the environment.
"I just want to do this to bring awareness.
Plastics are killing our planet, and I think
I have a solution."
Momoa continued, detailing that he's launching
a line of aluminum cans of water that are
completely recyclable.
According to the actor,
As he puts it,
"It's just water, but I feel good about it."
As Momoa cleaned up the last remaining hairs
on his face, he gave a little shout out to
his superhero character to drive his point
home, saying,
And now, apparently, so is Momoa.
A video as momentous as Momoa buzzing off
the beard he's had for the better part of
a decade was bound to garner a ton of attention,
and it got people talking.
Fans quickly flocked to the comments section
of the video and to Twitter to react to beardless
Momoa.
Many, like Twitter user @MissDonnaCooke, pointed
out the unfortunate truth that not only do
we live in a world where most people don't
recycle, but we now also live in a world where
Jason Momoa no longer has a beard.
She wrote in her post,
"Well done guys, first you destroyed the planet
and now you destroy Jason Momoa's beard.
I don't know which is worse.
Shame on you all."
She also appended the hashtag "bring back
the beard."
Judging by the reactions to the YouTube video,
which has drawn over 4 million views after
only a couple of days, people think Momoa
still looks great, with or without a beard.
Many were more blown away by the actor's activism
than by his new look.
As one fan wrote on Twitter, "With and without
beard!!
He's still attractive.
Jason Momoa shaving his beard for a good cause. Spreading awareness, and a solution."
At the end of the day, hair does grow back.
In a way, it's just as infinitely recyclable
a resource as aluminum.
So Momoa might again sport the lush Khal Drogo
beard his fans clearly love one day.
Whether or not that happens, though, one thing's
for certain: Momoa will continue trying to
save the planet, and that's arguably more
awesome than anything Drogo did in Aquaman.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.